what is your opinion on on online dating
and app dating you know in our
generation famously I think
Phil Collins broke up from his wife by
facts or something and everyone said
that's like the worst that a human
being's ever behaved and I mentioned
this to one of my children and they said
you have to break up by text they said
the thought of putting someone in the
position where they have to react to
your face about that level of rejection
they said that would be the ultimate
cruelty like my theory in life generally
Simon I mean apart from at the extreme
ends is Whoever likes anything most is
right yeah I mean if I don't like heavy
metal music and my son loves it he's
right the people who made the music
didn't make it for my ignorant ears I
think that if people are finding it
works
great